.
gleich am start
ihr glaubt nicht mit was für einem mist ich mich heute wieder rumschlagen musste man
heck wait
ich hasse so kack technik die nicht funktioniert obwohl sie eigentlich funktionieren sollte
weil man gescheit weil man massig geld für ausgegeben hat ich erzähl's euch gleich was
ein kram so
Leute wisst ihr was krasses so lange streams lohnen sich voll ich hab ich hab doch letztens
irgendwie fünfeinhalb stunden gestreamt oder so an dem tag habe ich mehr subs und und sachen
und alles gekriegt als als sonst irgendwie in drei tagen zusammen
deswegen ich kann schon verstehen dass teilweise nein nein nein kein kooper ne das mache ich
heute am feiertag nicht
ich hab mir so ein ding hier gekauft ja also
wollte ich jetzt sagen jetzt genau das verstehe ich aber um leute acht stunden am tag streamen
das irgendwie jeden tag die woche das scheint sich wirklich zu lohnen
letzte woche jemann bauch auf den neuen ramp für unseren server zu order und der etat anbuffert
ecc für apex oh das ist fail fail
pains champ
also ich sag euch mal was ich hasse analoge fernsehtechnik es gibt kaum was schlimmeres
also ich hab mir so ein ding hier gekauft auf anraten des chats also im prinzip im prinzip
ist der chat dran schuld dass ich mich heute wieder diesen miss zu aufregen musste also
passt mal auf ich nicht easy überhaupt überhaupt nicht easy also ich habe mir dieses ding gekauft
weil näher ich brauche irgendwas besser was ich brauche das gar nicht meine mutter brauche
was um fernsehe zu gucken weil die gerne fernsehe guckt ich kann es nicht verstehen und ich
will da irgendwas hinstellen was einfach funktioniert ohne dass ich da öfters zum support gerufen
werde ja ja die guckt die guckt wirklich den den den größten ja so wie wie ist das
so heile weltkram so rosa von der pilcher und was gibt's denn da noch inga lindström und
so die leute ich ich weiß es gar nicht alles aber es ist schlimm an der titel ist zumindest
es kann ja jeder gucken was er will soll er soll so machen zumindest ich hab was gesucht
gibt es auch ein schönes bild von dem teil oder so ach nee guck mal bei amazon in mein
basket habe ich das so ein teil drin also das ding habe ich mir bestellt hier so also
also hier wer hat es das teil auch starbucks ich vermute mal du guckst du guckst darüber
selbst fernsehen du striehmst nicht davon ich wollte das ding ja rein als box von der
ich streamen kann ich hatte zur auswahl eine fritz box und dann die tuner verwenden oder
das ding das ding ist eigentlich cooler von der technik her rein für dem vpt zumindest
also ich habe mir das teil bestellt also der wahrenkorb hier ist nicht mehr aktuell also
ich habe mir das ding bestellt und ich habe im wohnzimmer das kennt ihr ja aber das stream
da drüber ist übelster krab was hast du was hast du für eine was hast du für eine firmware
ja gut auf dem ipad ja ja ok da wird wahrscheinlich nicht gesüngt wohnzimmer setup wie ist denn
dieses video von mir hier also ihr wisst ja ich habe im wohnzimmer so einen sony fernseh
stehen also schild irgendwo hier ist das schild tv da unten steht irgendwie da das schild
tv das ist ein schild tv 2017 also da muss man eins eins muss man wirklich mal sagen nvidia
wirklich mal klapp klapper klaus also das ist nicht ohne das erste schild tv ist rausgekommen
ich glaube 2017 und es gibt bis heute immer updates und sogar ab und an mal eine neue android
version mittlerweile sind wir auf android weiß ich gar nicht neun oder so ne elf elf sogar
also die die bringen die bringen seit fünf jahren bringen die neue android also daran
könnten sich wirklich smartphone hersteller eine große schreibe abschneiden und die haben
glaube ich auch nicht auf aufzuhören so zumindest also mein setup sieht jetzt wie folgt aus
fernseh mit dem schild tv daneben besteht noch das switch aber die hat ja damit nichts
zu tun fertig reicht da ist kodi drauf und die ganzen apps die man braucht von amazon
und die media center apps und so zeugs also so und ich brauche jetzt irgendwas für den
fernseh empfang bisher bisher hatte ich hatte ich da ein raspberry pi 5 4 mit also raspberry
5 4 mit einem usb dual win tv tuner zum teil so tv hätten drauf raspberry pi gutes das
hat auch ganz gut funktioniert wobei ich da kein raspberry pi hatte ich hatte ursprünglich
ein also ich erzähle euch das jetzt bloß mal einfach dass ihr wisst wie das setup ist
und was ich jetzt habe so ursprünglich hatte ich mein android hc 1 oder hc 2 zum teil hatte
ich da ursprünglich mal dran das problem ist nur dieses ding hat beschissenen software
support und die das ist ab und zu gefriest und ich weiß nicht warum ich vermute mal weil
der kernel so alt ist was es dafür gibt und die treiber sag für den für den stick erster
punkt warum analoge fernsehtechnik absoluter abfuck ist so so dann bin ich umgestiegen
von dieser kiste habe ich die festplatte mitgenommen mit den ganzen aufnahmen und sowas
auf raspberry pi mit usb dual tuner das ding ist immer abgeschissen weil der raspberry
pi zu wenig strom geliefert hat an die usb anschlüsse selbst mit einem aktiven usb hub
hat es nicht gereicht für dual tuner und ssd unterlast stabil zu sein was hat man absolut
lächerlich ist aber gut ist also und da dachte ich mir jetzt ok weißt du was bevor du jetzt
lange rum frickelst entweder holst du jetzt eine fritzbox mit quad tuner drin und ersetzt
bei der gelegenheit auch gleich noch deine aktuelle fritzbox und dein unity media modem
durch dieses ding und alles ist gut oder die holst du so ein teil hier mit achtfach tuner
auch zum zum stream letztendlich habe ich mir beides bestellt so wie es hier drin ist
also das ist auch noch eine option aber dazu braucht man halt wieder ein raspberry pi mit
tv headend drauf tv headend ist tatsächlich ganz gute software wenn man fernseher empfangen
unterlinux machen will und aufnehmen und sowas so und heute habe ich mir gedacht ich richte
das ding mal ein das teil hier also dass das standard image was drauf ist sagt du musst
das flaschen schon mal das erste was raus raus bekommen habe gibt es zwei größere images
das eine image ist vti und das andere image ist open atv so vti ist quasi die offizielle
firma plus addons und open atv ist komplett open source hat nicht die aller neuesten treiber
aber deutlich neueres linux vti sagt zumindest was ich gesehen habe an aktualität von paketen
holst du die eigentlich diese ja habe ich schon ich habe die hier ich habe die hier liegen
also vti ist die linux seite ist ura ura ura ura alt damit kannst du nichts anfangen damit
läuft da läuft nichts drauf also wenn du wenn man vor hat beispielsweise da was irgendwas
anderes drauf laufen zu lassen als das was dabei ist an so viel dazu kannst du vergessen
also die version ist ura alt was bei bei diesem vti image dabei ist aber die haben ein paar
proprietäre treiber für ihre tuner drinne also prinzipiell ist das vti image gar nicht so übel
weiteres problem war dass im epg wenn ich das vti image verwendet habe keine genre und kategorien
angezeigt wurden wäre zu verkraften aber tv hätte ins contest und sonst wie war nicht so blöd war
nicht so schön also dachte ich mir was was war mal open atv drauf so habe ich auch open atv drauf
gemacht ist an sich das deutlich coolere image wenn da halt nicht die proprietären bestandteile
von dem wären die es ganz gut machen also sprich hier haben die halt irgendwelche close
source tuner treiber und sowas drinne womit das prinzipiell besser funktioniert beispielsweise
auch das ganze schnelle channel switchen und fragt mir nicht zeug proprietäres gedöns
vom linux unterbau her ist open atv viel viel besser du hast aktuelle libraries du hast
halbwegs aktuellen kernel halbwegs aktuell hast du halbwegs aktuelle python version drauf also
falls man da ein bisschen mit rumspielen will ist open atv viel viel cooler also habe ich
open atv drauf gemacht und jetzt geht es los habe ich das ding eingerichtet ist jetzt die
kurzfassung davon habe ich das ding eingerichtet ist auch wissenschaft für sich weil du das ding
mit der fernbedienung hier weil du das teil mit der fernbedienung einrichten muss zumindest bis
du dir ein web interface drauf gebastelt hast und dann klickst du fern und dann klickst du im
web interface die fernbedienung knöpfe also ist nicht so dass du den web interface gescheit was
machen könntest das hat zwar einstellungsmöglichkeiten im web interface aber die sind oftmals nicht so
synchron mit dem was du über die fernbedienung machst ist fernsehtechnik abfuck schon wieder
leicht ja gut also habe ich eingerichtet und dann kam der hit ohne scheiß ich habe alles importiert
ich habe mir sogar was gescriptet was meine tv hettent ich hesserzaun alter was meine tv hettent
aufnahmen also das da wäre schon mal tv hettent gesehen wir wissen das sieht uralt aus aber ist
eigentlich ein ziemlich cooles programm für fernsehempfang unter den jungs also ich habe
mir sogar was gescriptet wo ich meine alten tv hettent aufnahmen importieren kann in open
tv also ich habe mir quasi was gebastelt um das von hier nach hier zu importieren die aufnahmen
funktioniert kann man sich nicht beschweren funktioniert dann habe ich epg suchlauf machen
lassen habe automatische timer eintragungen gemacht für irgendwelche aufnahmen alles eingerichtet
eigentlich alles ganz gut ist ein bisschen kompliziert du brauchst ein paar addons dass
die beispielsweise in epg automatisch refreschen dass sie beispielsweise gucken ob in der
fernsehzeitung quasi programme auftauchen die du regelmäßig aufnehmen willst ist mega wir aber
habe ich gemacht dann kam der hit dann habe ich meinen mein kodi aufgemacht also ich habe
ja auf meinem schiel tv also auf der kiste habe ich ja kodi laufen das ist das was er hier auch
sieht zum fernseh gucken und sowas und sobald ich kodi starte hat dieser enigma prozess auf
diesem ding enigma ist quasi diese open source tunerfirma für ungefähr knapp über einer
minute 100 prozent cpu auslastung ich treffe heute nicht mal meine emotes 100 prozent cpu
auslastung für eine minute auf einer cpu warum dann stoppe ich kodi starte kodi wieder 100 prozent
cpu auslastung für eine minute das kann doch nicht sein warum hat es 100 prozent cpu auslastung ich
mein das macht nichts also wireshark angeschmissen reingeguckt was passiert ja gut ich habe zwar
plus 14 kanäle in meinen favoriten zum angucken aber das ding überträgt den kompletten epg 20
mal ich habe den wireshark damp das überträgt quasi 14 tage epg für 360 sender 14 mal oder
so das ding hatte ich habe gecaptured 22 megabyte text überträgt es 22 megabyte text muss reiner
text nichts rum rum nur der text beim start up und allein schon das auszulesen aus dem prozess
100 prozent cpu lasso und während das 100 prozent cpu las hat kann man den scheiß net verwenden
richtig absoluter krab wieder also sprich jedes mal wenn kodi neu gestartet wird darf ich erst
mal eine minute in der nase bohren damit ich mein fernseh bedienen kann ich glaube es geht los
ich glaube es geht los das bis kann das konnte ich so nicht benutzen ging nicht zumal das ding auch
ich habe dann mal ein bisschen in aufnahmen rumgeklickt was ist denn das für ein text
eine ganze bibliothek ja das ist das ist das ist der programm guide also quasi der die
fernsehzeitung für 14 tage für alle sender die man über dvbc wurde vorne empfängt und das
überträgt da quasi 14 15 mal weil es wahrscheinlich beschissen programmiert ist das ganze mache ich
übrigens mit dem kodi addon und das einzige kodi addon was es gibt kann man epg nicht zeitlich
einschränken doch aber das ist egal du kannst auf die channels einschränken es ändert sich
nichts du hast du hast eine minute frees warum ich nicht über vi plus gucke weil die bedienung von
von von der vi plus steinzeit ist mit der fernbedienung im vergleich zu kodi auf dem schiel tv
das schiel tv im kodi ist so weich ist so high res ist so gut zu bedienen da kommste dir da
kommste dir mit dem mit dem vti oder sonst was menü zurück versetzt in die steinzeit vor das
wirkt wie auf irgendeinem telefunken receiver von 1995 und mal ganz davon abgesehen ich will
ja auch die apps verwenden auf dem schiel tv von youtube bis prime bis mediathek und sonst was
die gibt es nicht da müsste ich jedes mal input switchen ich mein warum sollte ich das machen
und ganz davon abgesehen will ich ja auch im zweifelsfall auch mal an mehreren stellen im
haus fernseh gucken und ich möchte auch über die mobile app auch meine mutter soll das dann
machen über die mobile app aufnahmen programmieren können und die mobile apps für ios die die diese
enigma boxen unterstützen sind alle absoluter rotz ich habe so ausprobiert habe mir sogar
einige kauft also ein ausgeburt der an usability sowas habe ich selten gesehen zumindest als das
ding dann halbwegs funktioniert hat und bin ich zu dem schluss gekommen es ist unbenutzbar
freezes bei allem möglichen freest beim starten eine minute freest beim scrollen in aufnahmen
weil er epg refreshed ich habe alle möglichen settings durch durch probiert ich habe ich habe
gegoogelt wie sonst was löschen eine aufnahme dauert 45 sekunden weil am hintergrund irgendwelchen
shit zünkt also komplett komplett useless mit dem offiziellen streaming add-on in verbindung
mit mit dieser kiste so also dann habe ich mir gedacht fife hat das hat beide bei leute
ich habe euch misst ich habe ich miss erzählt das habe ich gestern gemacht ich habe heute
weiter gemacht so und habe ich mir gedacht sind wir mal fife fett und gucken ob es tv
hätten für die box gibt habe ich festgestellt es gibt tv hätten für die box also drauf
gegangen gerade dabei sind ich kann euch das kann euch das eigentlich sogar mal zeigen
warum zeige ich euch das nicht einfach ich darf bloß nicht das ist bei fau ti auch so
der sync ist so ich habe das ausprobiert ich habe das mit allen images und 40 andere probleme
ich habe das ausprobiert sobald oder start ist hast du eine minute epg sync das ist ja
auch logisch weil dieses enigma python zeug ist ja bei allem das gleiche die patchen das
zwar ein bisschen hin und zurück das muss man starten die patchen das zwar ein bisschen
hin und zurück aber im prinzip ist das gleiche ja das aufnahmen löschen dauert ungefähr
45 sekunden es sei denn es sei denn der hat gerade vorher frisch epg gesüngt dann nicht
ich weiß eh nicht warum er epg singt so und ich habe ganz viel ausprobiert useless komplett
useless also ich habe heute tv hätten drauf gemacht auf die box ich zeig es ich zeig
es euch mal schnell ohje da kriegt ihr höhenangst hier so t-marks also ich zeig es euch mal
schnell so eins zwei eins eins zwei neun yes root messer so da sind wir drauf guck ja sind
wir und was habe ich gemacht ich habe jetzt opkg list grab tv hendl ich habe tv hendl
installiert auf dem ding also ich habe quasi tv hendl auf einer linux tuner box installiert
und dann wollte ich es starten und dann war das problem er kommt mit den tunern von der
box nicht klar die tuner der box brauchen 30 sekunden zum umschalten oder gehen gar
nicht das ding hat nun root account sonst nichts anderes tv hendl habe ich einen extra
neuen account für gemacht das läuft unter hts das habe ich aber eingerichtet so tv
hendl kommt nicht klar mit den mit den tunern von diesem kackding so und jetzt jetzt habe
ich den fire fat move schlechthin gemacht ich habe mir ein ich habe mir ein sat ip bridge
installiert der die tuner im netzwerk bereit stellt und dann greife ich über sat ip auf
localhost mit tv hendl auf die tuner zu weil tv hendl selbst mit den tunern probleme hat
so und das funktioniert jetzt aber auch weiß nicht warum das so ein riesen akt ist also
ich hasse analoge fernsehtechnik ich meine es ist nicht wirklich analoge fernsehtechnik
mehr aber von den grundlagen her es ist einfach so ein shit warum kann der kram nicht einfach
funktionieren es ist ja noch schlimmer das originale addon hat so viele probleme zum
beispiel wenn man hier das offizielle streaming nicht tv hendl wenn man das offizielle streaming
nimmt warum nutzt du es da noch das ist doch nicht für mich ich benutze es doch so gut
wie gar nicht ich kann aber meiner mutter doch nicht sagen du darfst jetzt kein fernsehen
mehr gucken weil ich keinen bock hab die die kiste einzuschalten oder so ja die meisten
verwenden es wohl nicht nicht zum stream ja das stimmt stimmt wohl aber es ist halt kacke
dass es nicht funktioniert ich meine das ding hat ein achtfach tuner an liegungs drauf das
ist quasi prädestiniert zum stream zumindest das addon hat so viele probleme dass das ist
das kodi addon zum stream von der von der kiste wenn du eine aufnahme programmierst zeigt
dir die erst mit zwei minuten zwei minuten verzögerung an also du gehst in ein epg stellst
ein ich will jetzt rosamunde pilcher aufnehmen klickst das an und dann wird erst zwei minuten
später angezeigt dass die aufnahme registriert hat das muss ich mal vorstellen also was auch
immer sich die leute dazu recht programmiert haben ich verstehe es nicht und wenn du aufnahmen
löscht genauso zwei minuten später erst es ist wirklich ich hasse fernsehtechnik so grausam
so zumindest in dieser kombination funktioniert das halbwegs tv herrend aber ich wette mit
euch ich habe jetzt viele details noch ausgelassen weil schon ganz schlimm war was wieder nicht
richtig funktioniert hat es hat auch nur funktioniert weil ich meine alte kodi meine alte tv herrend
konfig importiert habe die neu einrichten hat gar nicht funktioniert ich wette mit euch
aber es gibt direkt probleme demnächst weil die tv herrend version von diesem openart
tv image ist halt auch von ende 2020 und sobald es probleme gibt kann ich keine neue
version drauf machen aus dem tv herrend selbst zu kompilieren das ist wirklich es ist schlimm
ich glaube ohne scheiß sollte ich werde parallel noch folgendes machen ich werde parallel mir
noch die fritzbox anschließen und in raspberry pie mit tv herrend aufsetzen dass ich im zweifelsfall
wenn das andere ding probleme macht dass einfach rüber kopieren kann und gut ist ich bin so
leid ich habe keinen bock mehr an fernsehsachen rum zu rum zu frickeln jaja ich weiß das
ist ja das schlimme das ist ja das schlimme also sprich die die guten lösungen ja sind
schon abfuck und die schlechten lösungen sind unbenutzbar überlegt euch mal man hätte
den offiziellen tuner von voter von wenn du den offiziellen tuner von voter von hast dann
können die dir verboten verboten dann können die dir verboten verbieten auf aufnahmen zu
machen im fernsehen oder verbieten zu spulen das muss man sich mal überlegen dafür bezahlt
ein geld bei denen und bezahlt geld dafür dass man verboten bekommt aufzunehmen und
du hast noch weitere probleme magenta tv mit kodi schauen da hast du andere probleme wenn
magenta tv mit kodi schaust weil das moment das andere probleme weil magenta tv definitiv
kein offizielles kodi add-on ist und nur wahrscheinlich ein community add-on das heißt verändert magenta
tv einmal was an ihrem kram geht es nicht und du kannst kein fernsehen mehr gucken
das ist ein problem und außerdem frage ich mich wie gut das mit aufnahmen und sonstigen
sachen funktioniert ja mal ganz davon abgesehen magenta tv weiß ich nicht ob das nicht geht
das mittlerweile auch ohne telekom anschluss magenta hat mittlerweile android app android
tv wenn man dann heißt das aber auch kann die aufnehmen kann die aufnehmen kann man
dann kann man dann festplatte an den tuner machen beziehungsweise an an der schiel tv
und speichert er die aufnahmen in der cloud oder lokal weil aufnahmen in der cloud ist
ist mist weil die meisten haben bloß 50 oder 100 stunden aufnahme in der cloud ist mist
in der cloud hast du nur 50 oder 100 stunden aufnahme das reicht nicht ein film ist eine
halb stunden lang und das sammelt sich über die zeit schon ein bisschen was an also auch
müll zartu ist auch müll weil zartu hast du entweder die offizielle dann musst du über
die cloud ich habe das ich habe schon einiges ich habe sogar weibhume ausprobiert da musst
du entweder über die offizielle app gehen das heißt du bist im prinzip auf gedei und
verderben von diesem anbieter abhängig und du kriegst glaube ich auch noch 50 stunden
record time oder record time und das kodi addon für zartu sagt das hat problem manchmal
hat hd programme anzuzeigen also ganz ehrlich es ist unglaublich wie beschissen es ist
fernseh zu gucken im vergleich zu wie einfach es sein kann youtube aufzumachen und video
anzuklicken oder netflix aufzumachen und video anzuglicken amazon prime aufzumachen
und video zu klicken also fernseh empfang in welcher art auch immer das ist das was
ich einfach mal wieder realisiert habe ist absoluter dreck ich hoffe dieser shit stirbt
bald aus was soll es denn mit wine zu tun haben jetzt marx ich habe eine frage ich muss
von arbeit aus an windows programm nutzen welche super super ressourcen fressen ist
das läuft ach so das mit wine probieren cacquait ich dachte immerhin soll es läuft nicht auf
den also umformen du wechseln wie hoch ist die performance verloss wenn ich man jaro
eine vm laufen haben wir sehen das kommt auf das programm an ob das gescheit funktioniert
generell muss man sagen windows virtualisiert unter linux das funktioniert passabel du kannst
natürlich so sachen machen wie gpu passthrough wenn du es richtig schnell haben willst aber
da hast du andere probleme dann brauchst du usb durchreichen oder monitor anschließen
wenn du da nicht noch mehr mit open looking class weiterleiten willst das macht es macht
es unnötig kompliziert also die normale windows vm virtualisiert unter linux funktioniert
aber der performance unterschied ist gerade in der in der oberflächen performance deutlich
spürbar also in der vm unter linux mit windows drinnen das merkt du dann dann ruckelt das
ein bisschen beim schieben und alles ob das jetzt schlimm ist bei dieser anwendung die
du verwendest weiß ich nicht ich würde dir tatsächlich empfehlen probiere mal nicht
nur kvm aus probiere mal virtualbox oder vor immer workstation unter linux aus die sind
was desktop virtualisierung angeht für windows besser als kvm wenn du auf dem server was
laufen lassen willst ist kvm natürlich erste wahl aber du willst ja desktop virtualisiert
haben und vielleicht auch ein bisschen performance in desktop programm probieren wir vor immer
workstation oder virtualbox so ich lese mir gerade leute ich habe glaube ich vorhin irgendwas
übersehen aber finde ich nicht mehr also falls irgendwas schreiker dankeschön für
den sub falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe sagt bescheid ich bin übrigens heute nur
angekommen um ein bisschen über mich über die analoge fernsehtechnik aufzuregen und
dass wir uns noch ein paar sachen angucken ich muss immer noch meine einkaufsliste vervollständigen
und wir können bisschen schwätzen ganz einfach zumal heute war fadertag ich war zwei stunden
wandern aber nicht mit meinem fader und ich habe sehr viele typen mit bollerwagen und
mit fahrrad gesehen ich bin gelaufen sag ich zwei stunden leute ich habe weiter abgenommen
stellt euch mal vor nein ich habe keine kinder ich bin ich bin kein fader zum glück ich
habe gesagt zum glück bin ich mit meinem fader rumgelaufen also was wollte ich jetzt sagen
ich habe noch weiter abgenommen leute stellt euch mal vor ich habe mich auf die ich habe
mich vorgestern was ich habe ich vorgestern auf die waage gestellt und ich habe jetzt
unter 99 ich habe jetzt 98 7 5 oder so es geht abwärts ich glaube dass viele bewegen
trägt dazu bei ja skill killer danke für den sub ok ich gehe jetzt schneller mal die
die fragen durch also es kommt ein bisschen aufs programm an ne wine sacked ich mein es
kann gut funktionieren je nachdem was es ist aber in der regel würde ich mal sagen also
wenn du auch darauf angewiesen bist dass die ganzen funktionen tun und so man kann es ausprobieren
aber je nachdem was es ist weiß nicht wein hast du halt so dinger so ja ich klicke jetzt
auf dieses wein bedienung ist ungefähr so ja oh cool die anwendung funktioniert richtig
gut in woin hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht dass das ganze so gut in wein funktioniert
bois ist cool oh crash das ist ungefähr die wine experience ja du denkst es funktioniert
alles gut dann klickst du in den menü an oder irgendwas was du vielleicht sonst nicht so
oft machst der crash aber es funktioniert erstaunlich gut mittlerweile also gut ich mein
ich wollte sagen es funktioniert erstaunlich gut dort wo es gut funktioniert aber das ist
ein ziemlich bescheuerter satz weil wein hat früher auch schon erstaunlich gut funktioniert
dort wo es funktioniert hat es funktioniert halt bei vielem nur nicht so komplett gut
ja das stimmt das habe ich bei der mutter versucht auch schon beizubringen mit der mediathek
app da können sie sich auch rosamunde pilcher und gedöns angucken weil ich habe mir auch
schon überlegt ob ich nicht einfach in eine ip tv liste von öffentlich rechtlichen mal
reinhauen tv herrennt und man schaut halt verzichtet halt auf private sender gut ist
so zumindest da da wäre ich froh wollte mir war für immer workstation pro ein ubuntu
linux vm nc alles funktioniert bis auf vermehrt tools der rinz aber ausgerufen was man kann
ich man der reinstall button du kannst sie doch einfach mounten guck mal kannst du auch
einfach sagen vm install ne manage ne warte mal wo ist das denn wo haben sie das versteckt
tatsächlich aber das ist nicht schlimm weil du musst die vm tools gar nicht darüber installieren
das macht eigentlich keiner mehr du gehst hierhin und sagst open vm tools und installierst
dir open vm tools open vm tools ist eh das bessere und das ist bei ubuntu mit dabei also
du brauchst keine du brauchst keine vm du brauchst es hier nicht drüber erzählen
du installierst aus dem repo open vm tools open vm tools ist das einzige was du brauchst
und dann vm vm tools d starten system ctl und alles funktioniert erst da musst du installieren
gibt es unter ubuntu auch oder unter ich habe heute bei meinem endeavor ist mit updates
den kernel gelöscht ist schlecht und jetzt booted nix mehr das ist halt ziemlich ziemlicher
sack deswegen mag ich übrigens vor immer workstation weil da kann man vor solchen
sachen einfach mal ein snapshot machen
weißt du ungefähr wie viele punkte deine azubi und ich habe keine ahnung skillkiller
danke für den sub kein schimmer ich hatte auch schon eine weile kein azubi mehr der
letzte azubi den ich hatte der ist mittlerweile fertig ja der ist mittlerweile fertig und
er hat die firma wo ich arbeite leider verkackt sich den zu sichern ich fand den nicht schlecht
der fand sich ein bisschen zu geil muss man sagen aber gut mein wie soll ich sagen also
gerade im alti bereich die leute die plan haben das sind oftmals relativ zurückhaltende
leute das heißt es ist mal gar nicht verkehrt wenn du einen hast der sich geil findet und
wenigstens ein bisschen plan hat weil ansonsten hast du eher leute die finden sich geil aber
die haben keinen plan und die leute die sich geil finden die haben irgendwelche selbstzweifel
und die leute die ahnung haben die haben meistens irgendwelche selbstzweifel und umso mehr ahnung
du hast umso mehr selbstzweifel hast du ob du überhaupt ahnung hast aber der hat sich
wenigstens selbst geil gefunden und hat ein bisschen ahnung also ich hätte sinnvoll gefunden
sie hätten sich dem azubi gesichert weil die suchen der inneren leute und einen den
man im gleichen unternehmen ausgebildet hat und der ahnung hat warum man den weggehen
lässt keine ahnung aber gut management stonks muss ich nicht verstehen a pfeiffer time ja
das kam das ist natürlich mit vms auch so bei angenehm einfach in den iso booten reparieren
und gut ist ansonsten bei ja bei offline sachen oder bei nicht vms muss halt mit usb stick
oder irgendwas oder mit cd leute meine freund habt ihr noch cd brenner hat jemand von euch
nur im cd brenner im rechner also ich nicht schon die letzten drei vier rechner generationen
nicht mehr aber echt was krass chat hätte ich nicht gedacht warum läuft denn wenn aus
heute meist so stabil und mit den looks habe ich schon zweimal dieses ab dieses jahr mit
updates zerschossen tja manches liegt auch wirklich an demjenigen der vorm rechner sitzt
weißt du nicht was du treibst ganz davon abgesehen es ist glückssache also ehrlich
anders ist glückssache du kannst bei windows pech haben bei jedem größeren update musst
du gucken gibt es irgendwelche news über dinger wie festplatte irgendwelche sachen
drauf kaputt boot manager zerstört bitt locker ist irgendwie kaputt irgendwelche anderen
sachen sind nicht richtig also jedes windows updates haben ganz viele leute sehr viele
probleme ich habe es bisher auch noch nicht abbekommen aber bin ich auch nicht scharf
drauf umgedreht kann es natürlich auch genauso sein dass wenn du irgendwie so einen bleeding
edge wie nennt sich nicht running update sondern wie heißt das wie das wie das arch macht
continuous update nie rolling release meine ich rolling release genau ja korrekt rolling
release kann dir das natürlich immer mal passieren dass ein bisschen was in die hose
geht wenn man das nicht will nimmt man debian und hat quasi beim release fünf jahre alte
pakete glaube ich auch nicht so sinnvoll ich finde ich finde arch basierte sachen am besten
für desktop nicht für den server habe ich irgendwas überlesen
ja debian geht nicht kaputt das stimmt also ich glaube ich habe es noch nie erlebt dass
in debian sich bei einem update zerschossen hat ich meine ich habe schon über ich habe
schon erlebt dass debian kaputt gegangen ist aber dass debian sich automatisch bei einem
update aus von selbst aus versehen zerschossen hat habe ich noch nicht gesehen was was ich
schon erlebt habe ist also wurden debian öfters kaputt gegangen ist das muss ich euch das
kann man der stelle auch mal erzählen weil es gibt schon echt ausgeburten der schlechten
ideen manchmal und zwar der provider bei dem ich damals gearbeitet habe der hatte ein eigenes
linux image auf debian basis für firewall installation ja im endeffekt war das in debian
mit iptables und das war eigentlich gar nicht so gar nicht so eine blöde idee aber es war
halt ein eigenes debian mit iptables minimal debian mit mit iptables also so minimal dass
es auf einer 128 mb kompakt kennt ihr noch cf flash kennt das ding noch jemand diese diese
länglichen dinger hier kennt noch jemand diesen krempel also das ding war so minimal
dass es auf einer 128 mb richtiger rennt noch ja ist so fehlt nicht mehr viel wenn ich doppelt
so alt bin bin ich in rente ja also die hatten das damals so gemacht die hatten in debian
abgespeckt dass es auf 128 mb kompakt flash passt und mit iptables das haben die für ihre
firewalls damals verwendet so zumindest weil zum thema debian geht nicht kaputt und jedes
mal wenn du was ändern wolltest musst du erst mal rewrite auf der kompakt flash karte anmachen
weil die dinger waren schalt meinsicht nicht man muss halt sagen das war äußerst robust aber
dadurch dass das so super krass minimalistisch war ich habe es noch nie erlebt dass ein linux
system kein support hat köln module nachzuladen also die haben köln modul support rausgepasst
dass das ding so klein war und auf kompakt flash karte gepasst also hast gesagt mod probe pc
speaker und das ding hat ihr einfach gesagt kann auch laut köln modules oder sowas also
sie haben die die haben den support für köln module auskompiliert irgendwie ganz wirres zeug
ja und dieses selbst gefrickelte provider debian linux das ist uns tatsächlich öfters kaputt
gegangen aber das lag weder an die das lag nicht so sehr an debian als an der ja die verunstalten
verunstalten debian was ich da verwendet haben tschüssi pro danke für den sub also das allerschlimmste
ist suze open suze kann ich überhaupt nicht ab haben wir haben wir irgendwelche open suzer hier
im chat ich mag open suze überhaupt nicht wir haben uns das mal angeguckt vor zwei jahren im
stream mal so dachte ich mir schauen wir mal vielleicht hat sich da was geändert ich fand
es einfach nur pains champ open suze redhead läuft tatsächlich auch gut das einzige problem bei
redhead ist ich glaube das ist das ist schon gut und gern zwei jahre her wenn ich wenn ich länger
aber wir haben doch archiv archiv archiv wo bloß wir gucken mal suze vor zwei jahren open suze
linux 20 jahre später gestreamt am 23.04.2020 ziemlich genau zwei jahre her moment jetzt wo
ich das moment wo ist er den song den muss ich jetzt mal wieder hören kakona song achtung
almost heaven twitch chat all these emotes hell yeah now we're older everyone's moved on
but i remember twitch chat twitch emotes
da war die welt twitch noch in erordnung ja
oh falsch rum people forehead bible thump twitch emotes
i remember typing dance game forehead swift rage pj salt and fail fish life was easy
spamming all the time t.o.s was nowhere so everyone's feeling fine twitch emotes along the goal
made you feel you're not alone
people forehead fortune sun ist richtig gekonert ja das mag sein aber das kann ich ja nicht spielen
der frankia z kennt auch keiner mehr
der frankia z
excellent song
herzlichen dankeschön
twitch emotes
twitch emotes okay sehr gut auch so nicht fertig twitch emotes fertig das muss jetzt mal wieder
sein krasses kokona video so was soll ich kommen projekt volterra microsoft bringt einen mini pizzi
auf armbasis für entwickler das läuft aber nicht auf windows iot oder das war weird champ wer will
mit so was entwickeln okay was läuft denn da drauf
sekunde ich hoffe man kann linux drauf machen jetzt ist die welt wieder in ordnung ja ist echt so
so lange so lange was ich eine runde mal den twitch emotes angehört alles alles gut also hier
projekt ich leute ich habe zu viele zu viele also kochla bla bla bla snapdragon plattform armen
testen microsoft windows system für den desktop ne please kein windows alter wer will denn unter
einem windows auf arm entwickeln jetzt mal ernsthaft warum also warum warum will man das machen was
warum warum
warum
also du willst das ding nicht kaufen du hoffst dir dadurch dass deswegen windows auf einem neuen
macbook laufen laufen könnte okay ja jetzt lasse ich mir noch gefallen aber diese ich meine darauf
sitzt darauf wird also ich meine ernsthaft wenn man sich das ding kauft wie was will man denn
entwickeln unter windows armen dann will man will man dort dann armen windows programme entwickeln
die keiner verwenden kann oder wie weiß nicht schimmer also verstehe es jetzt nicht was da
also ich wüsste jetzt nichts nichts damit anzufangen ehrlich gesagt alles armbasierte was ich hab ist auf
linux basis da bringt mir eine windows kiste herzlich wenig ich meine höchstens leute die
irgendwelche windows iot geschichten falls es das wirklich gibt programmieren wollen also ich sehe
jetzt ehrlich gesagt den anwendungszweck kann ich wir gucken mal was im ort der niedertracht so
geschrieben wird nämlich im heiseforum moment die haben dazu gar nix volt die haben dazu gar
nix ja dann dann gucken wir eben nicht was da geschrieben wird ja für windows auch die sachen
ok lasse ich mir gefallen aber ansonsten ansonsten linux beste ich meine unter windows kann man so
was hier schon mal nicht machen ja das wäre also wenn das jetzt schon mal kein anzeichen dafür
ist dass es ziemlich poc jam ist linux zu verwenden und nächstes jahr nicht heise das heiseforum
das heiseforum ist ein ort der niedertracht ich bin gar nicht sicher ob man das wort überhaupt
so verwenden kann niedertracht niederträchtige gesinnung ja alles das meine ich ja das meine ich
boshaftig ja also das heiseforum ist ein ort der niedertracht genau so deshalb überhaupt meine ich
dass nicht heise sondern das heiseforum und wenn du nicht weißt warum das heiseforum dann
lest dir einfach ein paar news kommentare durch und dann bin ich mal gespannt was du dann zu sagst
die zivoren teilen einträge die sind gewollt also das ist teilweise im heiseforum so dass du
eigentlich schon davon ausgehen kannst dass ein großteil der kommentare nur noch geschrieben wird
um quasi wie nennt man das zu beten also also quasi reactions zu beten und die schreiben quasi
absichtlich was um um dumme reaktionen drauf zu zu beten wo wir gerade dabei sind mal kurz schauen
wie ist denn die cpu auslastung jetzt mit tv headend auf meiner linux tuner box geht eigentlich
oder guckt mal satt ip hat ein bisschen cpu auslastung das ist aber nicht schlimm satt
ip hat cpu auslastung und tv addend hat cpu auslastung aber eigentlich alles noch im grünen
bereich kann ich mit leben solange das solange das ding nicht irgendwie in zwei tagen anfängt
wieder ultra probleme zu machen ist alles gut golem finde ich geht halt halbwegs also heise ist die
größere seite muss man sagen weil alles ist ja auch schon beispielsweise an den kommentaren zahlen
also hier hast du mal ein paar mit vielen aber die meist haben nichts bei heise haben eigentlich die
meisten lotus auf linux das brauche ich finde golem ist nicht ganz so wild in den kommen in
den comments aber auch in aber da doch ähnlich aber nicht ganz so beschissen ähnlich ähnlich
aber ich finde es ein bisschen angenehmer im golem form was ich was ich tatsächlich immer noch ganz
gerne les ist computer base da sind die nicht ganz so ganz so ätzend drauf also computer base
finde ich tatsächlich ganz ganz nett ab und zu mal zum zum prüberscrollen und ansonsten ohne mist
reddit reddit subscription feed also nicht reddit startseite sondern die reddit startseite mit
subscribten channels fertig und wenn ich nichts besseres zu tun habe gehe ich auf reddit mit
meinem smartphone und gucken die startseite an also meine startseite und da finde ich meistens
irgendwas ja da ich habe ja alles mögliche wie heißt das eigentlich heißt das abonniert auf
reddit gefollowed auf reddit ja also was weiß ich von homelab ist beispielsweise super seite wenn
man sich für it krempel interessiert gerade halt sachen wenn man schauen was die leute daheim so
bauen self-hosted ist eine super geschichte sys admin ist super super super sub reddit gibt gibt
einige ja dann ich habe sogar ihr werdet mir nicht glauben leute ich habe java script sub reddit
abonniert weiß auch nicht was mich da geritten hat ich habe glaube ich so 30 30 35 sub reddits nur
das wo ich halt auch gerne lese und unter anderem was letzte preis habe ich auch abonniert ganz
wichtig was letzte preis muss auf dem aktuellen absolut auf dem aktuellen stand sein übrigens
wusstet ihr dass mein ebay klein anzeigen konto gesperrt wurde ich habe mich gestern versucht auf
ebay klein anzeigen einzuloggen und dann habe ich meine email adresse eingegeben und ich dachte mir
eigentlich ich habe gar keinen account und ich wollte mir den account anlegen und da hat er mir
gesagt ich hätte schon einen account dann habe ich meine email adresse eingegeben und dann hat
er gesagt die account ist gesperrt und ich habe in meinen emails geguckt ich habe keine mail von
ebay klein anzeigen für diese email also ich habe mail history über imap von den letzten 15
jahren oder so also ich habe keinen ebay klein anzeigen account je besessen aber ebay klein anzeigen
ist der meinung mein account für ebay klein anzeigen ist eingeschränkt weil ich habe keine
ahnung ich habe kein ebay klein anzeigen account ich habe auch nicht nach was letzte preis gefragt
ich habe mir überlegt ob ich mir nicht noch ein zwei nexus point kaufe für den keller dann kann
ich den einheben nämlich im ersten stock da habe ich noch einen im keller weil im keller ist der
empfang bei manchen ein bisschen grenzwertig geht halt durch zu viel durch ich habe jetzt einen
support geschrieben von ebay klein anzeigen ich bin mal ich bin mal gespannt ob ich jemals
eine antwort bekomme wait a minute kundenservice deutsche bahn hat mir was geschrieben das ist
doch das ist doch china das ist doch nigerianischer prinz oder sowas oder
ja das ist spam
das ist das ist das ist spam ich hätte gedacht die sagen ich krieg mein geld wieder oder sowas
aber no pass noch zu schön habt ihr euch schon ein euroticket gegönnt wollt beim rmv gucken da
gab es nichts dass ich beides in der abkapp wo gibt es denn das jetzt eigentlich in dem in
den verkehrs verbunden verkehrs verbünden apps gibt es den kram ja nicht so bei der bahn in
der app gibt es das ja wohl schon übrigens warum ist eigentlich die db app noch schlechter
geworden in letzter zeit früher konnte man beispielsweise in dieser in der strecken agent
konnte man zum beispiel gescheit sehen an welchem kleis die züge halten auch wenn es nicht mein
zielbahnhof war und solche dinge das ist wir geworden ne ne du kannst kein ice fahren du kannst
aber überall fahren also warum ist regional ist ja ne also ja du kannst nur mit regional express
so was fahren aber du kannst überall fahren nicht nur regional aber du kannst nur das nicht
ice fahren ich glaube ic das du auch nicht fand ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich bin mir grad nicht
sicher es gab letztens was da habe ich mir grad warum ist die app so verschlimm besser geworden
schauen wir doch mal bahn.de das ist die webseite ist auch verkackt sekunde also suchen wir mal
hanao von hanao hauptbahnhof auf bau hauptbahnhof nach frankfurt hauptbahnhof so suchen maro dort
die seite ist gut ja die kenne ich so details einblenden ic
ne hier ist es hier ist es tatsächlich noch da dann weiß ich nicht mehr was mich gestört hat
vielleicht habe ich mich einfach nur aufgeregt und es ist gar nichts da was mich stört
ich meine das kann ja auch sein aber die seite ist wirklich top die verwende ich auch sehr
oft da gab es einen vortrag drüber auf dem ccc von dem typ der diese seite seite entworfen
hat wisst ihr wie das funktioniert das ist richtig fifeheader der hat die api reverse
engineered von irgendwie 40 verkehrsverbund webseiten und er ruft jetzt quasi zug information ab nicht
nur über die bahn api sondern von 40 verschiedenen verkehrsverbünden also weil es gibt ja viele
züge die fahren übergreifend und dann macht das so einen best of für den jeweiligen zug daraus
und das ist genauer als die bahn apps das ist zuverlässiger als die bahn apps und es steht
auch schon sachen in der drinnen wenn es in der bahn nicht drin steht also eigentlich richtig ist
fife sagt mal was ist da gerade in frankfurt los guckt euch das mal an kommt hier überhaupt
irgendwas pünktlich guckt euch das mal an das ist doch lächerlich guckt mal hier es ist ja
eigentlich alles rot guckt guckt euch diesen bullshit an wieder guck es euch an an heute ist
feiertag das ist doch lächel es ist so ein ficker laden alter die bahn meine güle guckt
euch das an es kann doch nicht sein dass das 50 50 wenn wenn das 50 50 ist ja das ist mehr
als 50 das sind das sind 70 30 es geht aber auch um kaputte türen ja türen sollten auch
nicht kaputt sein aber der meiste sache ist nicht hier wegen stellwerkstörung ist was anderes aber
krass oder 70 prozent rot das ist so beschissen das ist so ein dreck laden man die können wir
eigentlich als viertreichstes land der welt zumindest wirtschaftsmäßig so beschissen sein
in diesem sektor das ist doch gar nicht das geht doch eigentlich gar nicht egal ich will
jetzt mich nicht wieder über die bahn aufregen kommst du aus hanoi ja komm ich ja ist auch so
ich will leute ich will ich will es gar nicht ich will nicht wieder von der bahn anfangen sonst
reg ich mich da wieder dann reg ich mich bis 22 uhr auf wenn ich wenn ich mich will ich fange
ich fange davon jetzt nicht an es waren in der zeit wo die bahn kaputt gespart war so gut wie
alle parteien mit an der regierung das kann man keinem einzeln in die schuhe schieben das ist
eine gesamtleistung hallo ist cool schaffenburg ist besser warum warum ist gerade erschaffenburg
besser außer dass man deutlich länger nach fangfort braucht was findest du besser dual
boot linux und windows oder mit vmware tools was findest du besser dual boot linux soweit
verstehe ich als dual boot windows und linux oder mit vmware tools was willst du denn unter
was virtualisieren also ich persönlich würde immer vorziehen windows und linux in a vm mit
vmware tools besser besser geht es eigentlich nicht passwort leak leute oh mein gott ich habe
das passwort für mein linux set-top box vom fernsehe gelegt jetzt ist vorbei man cute schlieg die
musik passt da richtig gut dazu oder github trends wollen wir mal gucken schauen wir mal
trendet trendet bestimmt in der china chinesen kram was spricht denn was spricht denn gegen
windows wenn du windows braucht mit linux als vm warum muss es ein linux host sein was willst
du machen dass es linux host sein muss es kann ja durchaus legitime können durchaus legitime
gründe haben aber ich finde es virtualisiert sich linux deutlich besser unter windows als
windows unter linux privacy näher es hält sich doch keine ab die kritischen sachen unser linux
in a vm zu machen ja surfen und sowas ist überhaupt kein problem handelsblatt was sagen die dann das
deutsche banner steht vor dem fall ja ja ja das problem ist dass die keinerlei persönliches
interesse daran haben das zu verbessern dort in den führungspositionen hast du schon gesehen
was passiert wenn im ascii qua das mausrad bewegt ja es geht schneller hier es flutscht
huge massive speed guck zu euch an
kann man das vorspulen guck mal und dann braucht das guckt euch mal 65 prozent cpu braucht es jetzt
krasse 65 aber übrigens ich glaube es ist nicht nur ich glaube es ist nicht nur das mausrad ich
glaube es sind alle tasten ja guck mal bild hoch bild runter gedrückt halten ist genauso
ok wir gucken mal auf wie viel cpu auslastung bekommen wir das ganze wenn ich tasten spamme
ok auch nicht mehr außer dass es abkackt das ist voll verreckt gerade auch ich habe es zerstört
leute ripp ascii qua ja unglaublich
das würde ich anstelle der schweizer auch machen
ja github trends zeig mal was was trendet denn auf auf shit hub
ja das habe ich keinen bock heute drauf
wenn du in beiden betriebssystemen eine grafikkarte brauchst brauchst du linox als das ist richtig
wüsste ich jetzt nicht wie das gehen soll
ach so du meinst mit hyper wie du meinst mit hyper wie dieses ja ja ich weiß was du meinst
aber hyper wie auf dem desktop ist doch doch hyper wie kann das hyper wie kann das mit
dings du hast recht hyper wie kann das mit diesem von nvidia wo du grafikkarten splitten
kannst mit wo du die quadro diese 2000 euro grafikkarten splitten kannst auf mehrere vms
ja ja ja aber das macht ja kein kein normaler mensch
naja mal davon abgesehen ich muss sagen es funktioniert unter linux in der vm alles ganz
brauchbar das einzige was halt wirklich bisschen doof ist ist hd videos gucken weil hd videos
gucken da reicht das bisschen bisschen 3d 2d beschleunigung das vm kann nicht aus da
bräuchtest du einen hardware decoder das ist halt nicht so viel cpu leistung braucht und
das ist halt wirklich dumm
ich weiß ich hatte irgendwo geschrieben warum er unbedingt linux windows auf linux haben
möchte gucken du kennst sicherlich auch den trick mit f5 im task manager nö was ist das
für ein f5 trick
ach du meinst dass der aktualisiert ja das ist aber doch kein trick für den task manager
das geht doch überall
wird gl ja das habe ich mal ausprobiert aber vor fünf jahren oder so als es noch total
neu war da hat es nicht gut funktioniert ansonsten vom ansatz her finde ich das sehr nice ich
bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher wie das wie das genau funktioniert hat ich glaube du
musstest die grafikkarte musstest du die grafikkarte im client haben der das anzeigt oder musstest
du die grafikkarte im host haben wo die vm drauf läuft
ich glaube im host oder ich bin mir da jetzt aber nicht mal sicher
das wäre naheliegend
was ist das für windows man sieht aus wie das ist i3 das ist ein bisschen wie awesome
ja es geht in die gleiche richtung
zumindest mit der gpu splitten geht doch inzwischen auch so glaube ich zumindest mit der 90 echt
cool wusste ich nicht
müssen wir mal ausprobieren
geht hyper die frage ist geht das unter windows 10 pro oder braucht man dafür windows server
ipad alter wusste ich
wenn ich aber linux nutze weil ich windows nicht vertraue kann ich nicht das stimmt
also wenn du dir denkst dass dort quasi das rootkit mitgeliefert wird der im zweifelsfall
dein interface tcp dampf oder microsoft schickt oder oder sonst wohin ja ne dann nicht das
ist so das ist richtig dann kannst du keinen windows als host benutzen das ist richtig
nvidia hat linux open source gemacht den linux driver open source gemacht das kann durchaus
sein dass das unter linux für virtualisierung was bringt
das hat mich so aufgeregt heute mit diesem fernsehkram ich bin total müde
gut vielleicht bin ich auch müde weil ich so viel draus umgelaufen wird kann auch sein
ihr werdet ihr werdet es kaum glauben aber wenn ich so mein arm angucke ja und dann und
dann so das hemd mal hoch schiebe oben am arm dann ist der arm oben weiß und der arm
unten ist raun es gibt sachen die hätte ich selbst vor noch zehn jahren nicht möglich
gehalten dass mein arm im sommer färbung hat es ist eigentlich war das immer ein ding
der unmöglichkeit aber mittlerweile hat der farbe im sommer
wahnsinn sagen gibt's hätte ich selbst nicht für möglich gehalten deshalb kein windows
dark mode
ich habe nichts was wir machen können ich habe einfach den stream angeschmissen weil
ich mir noch auf die schnelle so paar so paar notizen so nach dem motto ach ja darüber
heute ist feiertag ach so moment aber nur bei uns heute die stonks sind mal hochgegangen
260 euro tatsächlich wahnsinn die letzten jahre die letzten keine ahnung zwei monat
die stonks nur runtergegangen nein war ich nicht nein machen wir nicht github verse github
versus gt warum man könnte auch noch gocks nehmen gocks gibt es auch noch das gta glaube
ich mal ein fork von gocks aber ich habe gta github finde ich mittlerweile zu bloated für
ein heimbereich fork nice ach wir wollten wir wollten github trends gucken lass mal kurz
schauen trending bestimmt china chinesen graben die amd kompo tech 2022 note schon gesehen
nö gibt es irgendwas spannendes neue cpus vergisst jedoch etwas wichtiges zu erwähnen
da hätten sie mal die games da fragen sollen vorher github self-hosted ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher ob das habe ich noch nie gesehen also ich weiß dass es das gibt aufgrund dessen
weil ich mal irgendein api api guide gelesen habe wo es um self-hosted github ging ich
habe noch nie erlebt dass das irgendjemand gemacht hat
ist wahrscheinlich pain in the ass das zu administrieren also was haben wir denn was
was trendet denn auf github in der high IQ developer welt was ist denn was ist am trend
also panel speech easy to use speech toolkit including sota und streaming asr ich hab keine
ahnung was das ist aber ok wenn man sich damit auskennt dann weiß man das wahrscheinlich
text to speech kenne ich was ist asr und sota ist irgendwas recognition irgendwas recognition
sonst war stop war keine ahnung ich weiß nicht so core ist am trend implementation of tera
protokoll keine ahnung was das tera protokoll ist payload ein cms noch ein cms verbraucht
es gibt aber es gibt so mega viele cms wann genau verwendet man sowas eigentlich ich frage
mich das ernsthaft die ganzen leute früher irgendwelche wordpress seiten gemacht oder
was gab es dann noch trupal gab es dann noch und und das mit c mit c gab es auch irgendwas
es gibt so viele cms dinger und ich frag mich so wann genau verwendet man die eigentlich
also ich hatte noch nix noch kein projekt und noch nix was ich daheim machen wollte
oder was immer wo ich mir gedacht habe typo typo da bräuchte ich jetzt ein cms für also
ich habe echt keine ahnung warum man das verwendet so flipper desktop debugging platform
von mobile developers von facebook da ist der zuck eingebaut da begrüßt sich dann
der zuckerberg avatar oder so am handy demnächst ok das braucht man aber wahrscheinlich wirklich
weil wenn man mobile developer ist weil 11.000 sterne hast du nicht von heute auf morgen
so key to ps4 und ps5 emulator und ein ps5 emulator gut warum nicht ich mein eine ps5
ich könnte mir zumindest vorstellen ich rate mal ich habe mich damit nicht beschäftigt
ich würde ich würde mal vermuten dass der unterschied betriebssystem mäßig zwischen
ps4 und ps5 gar nicht mal so groß ist unter der haube ist das ja alles ein bsd mit proprietärem
sony kram drum herum kitty vladimir m graphics for ps5 not yet implemented ok simple run
für ps4 ok das ist so proof of concept dass es das gibt aber man hat es gesehen bei den
anderen emulatoren da wird teilweise richtig krass progress gemacht in kurzer zeit also
das sollte man mal auf dem schirm haben china all defense tool aus china alles klar trendet
also wenn ihr wissen wollt was es macht jetzt wissen wir bescheid all defense tool google
translate wir moment wir übersetzen es jetzt erst mal herklich herzlichen glückwunsch
zum fund des schatzes dieses projekt integriert hervorragend offensiv und verteidigungs waffen
projekte im gesamten netzwerk einschließlich zu zum sammeln von information ist das ist
das irgendein ja ist es ist es so eine exploit sammlung oder oder sowas so was richtung metas
ploi oder so keine ahnung china kali linux keine ahnung was es ist aber es trendet all
defense tool finde es übrigens cool dass das ding all defense tool heißt und dann
drinne steht dass man irgendwie was angreifen kann das ist das also da werden sich in dem
punkt wenn sich die schitten wenn die chinesen mit den amis einig asp.net core trendet die
haben es verdient poggers framework rising wave next generation streaming database in
the cloud das ist so ein projekt ich habe legit keine ahnung was es ist aber ich könnte
wetten das ist so neumodischer poggers scheiß dass du wahrscheinlich dich nicht traust das
in produktiven anwendung zu verwenden cloud native streaming database ich habe legit
keine ahnung was eine cloud native streaming database sein soll aber vielleicht erklären
sie uns das ja realtime applications ok es verdaut oder es bekommt da daten von kafka
pulsa kinesis red panda alles klar einzige was ich davon kenne ist das hier das habe
ich glaube ich schon mal irgendwo gelesen das habe ich noch nie gehört und red panda sagt
mir gar nichts
your first query
ich habe keine ahnung was es ist
schon was mit dotnet maui gemacht nein absichtlich nicht ihr wisst ja ich bin riesen dotnet fanboy
und sie scharpe fanboy aber maui ist für mich finde ich ist der falsche ansatz und finde ich
nicht lernenswert aktuell
da haben wir doch ein dotnet maui workshop
das ist ein bisschen wie xamarin forms das wurde auch nie wirklich fertig und im prinzip
ist maui ja xamarin forms nur mit neuem namen und ohne linux support
chakra ui das kenne ich das ist eng das ist glaube ich für react genau für react irgendwie
so eine komponenten sammlung ja ich persönlich kann da wenig zu sagen ich bin bisher noch
nicht dort wirklich an die grenzen vom entity framework gelaufen aber ich habe es auch im
kleinen stil schon gemerkt dass das entity framework manchmal die sachen etwas doof
macht zum beispiel habe ich mal in postgres versucht ein autocomplete zu programmieren
das haben wir sogar im stream gemacht ein autocomplete mit der postgres textindex geschichte
also dass man quasi während man tippt in inform suggestions bekommt so vorschläge
was man denn tippen kann und ich musste von hand postgres metoden ihm sagen was er verwenden
sollte weil er ansonsten so sachen gemacht hat wie case sensitive vergleich obwohl es
nicht case sensitive gewesen ist und und dinger also es war nicht sonderlich so gut optimiert
aber an sich hatte ich noch nie probleme damit so im großen und ganzen es war immer schnell
genug bisher aber ich könnte mir vorstellen wenn man wenn man da wirklich krassen datenbank
shit macht dass es dann probleme macht dass es halt die sachen für dich generiert und
es halt nicht unbedingt immer das rauskommt was du haben willst so also was was gibt es
hier noch wie spricht man das auf mutt joko multijoint dynamics contract ein physik physik
simulator cooles zeug da wir halt in screenshotten aber bei das ist glaube ich gar keine library
oder das ist nix mit mit ausgabe includes native gui ja dann wäre doch wirklich blau
wenn es ein native gui included da wäre doch wirklich schlau einfach mal den screenshot
rein zu machen oder hi torch package für irgendwelche dinger machine learning kram siegmar chat
keine ahnung was es ist sing fusion react gedöns javascript spring naja java zeug darf
auch nicht fehlen ab und zu ab und zu ist es erlaubt dass mal ein bisschen java präsent
ist ist darley nicht diese zeichen ai vom namen her wird es passen ja go mocking framework
super das kenne ich das haben auf der arbeit auch speak messenger fast jason fast jason
parser generator for java ok also ist standard library jason in java anscheinend nicht fast
so hier noch mal schnell code edit code editor warum das denn ach so mek only ok dann sieht
er wahrscheinlich wenigstens gut aus screenshots ja er sieht er sieht ganz hübsch aus das
muss man ja mit denen lassen das können die das können die mec apps doch die sehen alle
tatsächlich ganz gut aus standardmäßig wobei das ohne probleme html interface sein könnte
es sieht auf den ersten blick ziemlich nach bruschel studio code aus und die haben sich
den kram auch von so pleitex damals gemobst ist es denn schauen wir mal ist es ist es
denn javascript nähe ist es swift das kein elektron leute es ist swift clean templates
für go go ist nicht clean genug normal maui workshop samples anime bestes repo kenne das
das ist das ist das beste repo überhaupt anime girls holding programming books welche sprache
wollten wir uns wollen wir uns mal angucken holi holi sie holi sie ok achtung excellent
holi sie programming language holi sie learning basics holis alles klar so ist mal bescheid
das ist das beste beste repo beste repo hier sie schabt sie schabt gibt es tatsächlich
richtig viele guckt euch das mal an ich hoffe da hat ich hoffe da hat nicht irgendeine hentai
krams dazwischen gemischt und jetzt mache ich das im stream auf excellent sie schabt
wo ist das sie schabt buch ach da cla buch ok pro sie schabt 7 sehr gut sie schabt 7
ist zwar nicht wirklich aktuell wir sind glaube ich jetzt bei 11 demnächst aber immerhin sie
schabt programming endlich dotnet 2.0 el assembler holi sie denn das ist nicht wirklich eine
echte sprache doch das ist eine echte sprache aber es ist jetzt keine sprache die man ernst
nehmen muss excellent jetzt wissen wir auch bescheid wie das aussieht mein cute anime
grills holing programming books machen armor reforged samples selenium helm china chinesen
zeug oder sonst wie sagen ist jetzt für mich persönlich nicht so viel wahnsinnig interessantes
in den github trends gewesen aber holi sie ist tatsächlich echt weiß gar nicht ob es
mittlerweile auf github gibt holi sie das ist das ist das temple os genau temple es ist in
holi sie programmiert hat china nicht ein eigenes github china hat alles gegen den eigenen
klon die haben die alibaba cloud und und zeugs sie nur 33 monat für den sub talk to god on
up to 64 course final snapshot oh nee entwickel das keiner mehr weiter wollen wir temple os
mal starten leute nicht heute aber in einem der nächsten streams einfach mal temple os
in der vm anschalten und gucken was uns da erwartet ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber
nee heute machen wir das nicht ich gehe zehn minuten auf issues gibt pull requests es möchte
keiner so wirklich mitarbeiten an temple os oder temple os org der typ hat auch in richtigen
dachschaden gehabt der wurde ja vom zug überfahrende temple os erfinder aber der hat der hat auch
einen ziemlich krassen dachschaden gehabt der du aber wer programmiert sonst ein betriebssystem
in holi sie weil er irgendwie eine vision von gott hat die ihm gesagt hat dass ein dass
das göttliche betriebssystem keine ahnung 64 64 farben brauche oder so also der hat
ja wirklich behauptet der typ also irgendeine vision hatte und gott hat ihm quasi übermittelt
was er für ein betriebssystem programmieren soll und also da musst du schon einen harten
dachschaden haben dass du dir sowas einbildest du bist ja sprichst du mit gott bist du religiös
spricht gott mit dir bist du verrückt es gibt viele verrückte in der richtung dass das
ist ernst das ist mega ernst gemeint temple os der zwar richtig der richtige hardcore
dude also der hat der hat sein leben lang temple os entwickelt ja das ist ernst gemeint das
ist kein witz der man der muss richtig feifett gewesen sein so feifett dass er irgendwann
von zug gelaufen ist wobei man da glaube ich gar nicht so genau weiß ob es jetzt absicht
war oder nicht aber der war er der hatten wirklich in richtig krassen knall gehabt der temple
os typ so aber shit hab zu boah ich bin so kaputt aber es ist auch wirklich anstrengend
gewesen erst gewandert und dann komischen analogen fernsehkrempel gemacht der nervig
ist not pock heute mal ich habe eine frage an euch noch eine arbeits story kann ich machen
muss ich überlegen ich habe eine frage an euch hat einer von euch noch ein ipad 6 ipad
6 release das ist glaube ich von 2000 eigentlich 18 oder so anwalt ipad 6 release date ne ne
2018 also ich habe noch eins und das ist richtig langsam aber wenn man es rebootet dann ist
es wieder kurzzeitig sehr geschwind also sprich wenn ich das tablet für eine woche an habe
und ich webseiten aufmache die ein bisschen fordernder sind ja weil es halt eben ein paar
animationen hatten sonst wie was dann ist es langsam ruckelt baut sich kaum auf ich
reboote das ding alles top habt ihr eine idee was das sein könnte warum muss man sein ipad
rebooten dass es ordentlich läuft wieder das kenne ich ansonsten nur von windows sachen
resetten aber warum soll ich es resetten ich meine ich will den kram doch behalten der
da drauf ist gut da muss ich vorher ein backup machen ne speicher ist nicht voll akkuleistung
dann du meinst dass der akku leer ist und sich das irgendwie trosselt oder so ne der
akku ist also wie gesagt ich habe richtig probleme wenn es paar wenn es eine woche läuft
ist es lamas fack dann reboote ich sondern geht es wieder und das dürfte ja durch reset
sich eigentlich nicht lösen oder aber ich habe da halt auch schon einige ios version
durch abgecrated wie guckt man denn die akkuleistung überhaupt nach in system settings oder ist
das irgendwie so ein pfeiffer zeug was apple nicht will dass man sieht aber wenn ich resette
wenn ich resette und vorher ein itunes backup mache oder so dann kann ich es ja einfach
wieder restoren und gut ist ach so ja dann einstellung akku ich guck mal ich guck mal
ja also es ist mega langsam nach einer woche und dann reboote ich das und dann funktioniert
es ich habe mir schon überall also ich habe den vergleich damit ich habe ja auch noch
ein neueres ipad und das hat überhaupt keine probleme das kann ich wochenlang in der ecke
liegen lassen und dann mache ich es an und das ist zackig blöd weil ansonsten ist das
noch top das nicht eher nach einem rem issue ich habe ja nichts offen ich habe da ich habe
da vielleicht youtube app offen aber ansonsten nix kann ja schlecht ramauslastung sein ich
meine von wo soll es herkommen oder sie haben es einfach mit betriebssystem updates langsam
gepatcht und sie wollen dass ich mir noch ein neues ipad kaufe ich trau ich trau den
alles zu
es läuft auch problemlos aber webseiten sind langsam gerade bisschen komplex aber auch
nur nach einer woche nach dem reboot sind die schnell und alles funktioniert keine ahnung
was das für ein kram ist vielleicht sollte ich doch mal resetten resetten und und dann
back up wieder wobei bringt der reset eigentlich was wenn ich danach das back up wieder einspiel
weil dann ist doch eigentlich alles so wie vorher oder sind die sachen dann da nicht
mit im back up oder wie oder was also oder soll ich resetten und lieber nochmal neu
anmelden überall ich meine viel ist da nicht drauf ein paar bilder und youtube ansonsten
ist ja nicht viel aber mal gucken mal gucken heute ich mache jetzt mal ein paar tabs zu
mir gerade ein bisschen zu viel sogar mir so das lassen wir auf nee speicher ist nicht
voll da ist nichts drauf hab da nie großartig was drauf gemacht das hat zwar nur 16 g aber
da ist nichts drauf also da ist ein browser drauf der ist standardmäßig dabei und youtube
fertig sonst nix da ist beste man kann natürlich auch zwei aber eins lässt sich am besten
copy pasten wobei ich eins nicht copy paste sondern ich hatte die eins einer unterschied
install oder ich lasse es einfach so ich meine ich verwende zum größten teil ja das andere
aber gerade wenn ich mal auf dem klo es liegt auf dem klo falls gerade wenn ich auf dem klo
bin und im browser aufmachen will dann ruckelt das rum und ich habe keinen bock dann erst
mal das ipad neu zu starten dass ich ordentlichen browser verwenden kann man könnte jetzt sagen
messer first world problems ist ein scheiß pad genau man könnte jetzt sagen messer first
world problems aber ich hätte doch gerne ein funktionierendes tablet auf dem klo ich
mein wer kennt nicht die besten ideen hast du beim kacken wenn auf dem klo sitzt oder
sonst nix da fangen da fallen dir teilweise richtige fife header sachen ein und dann
musste mal kurz was nachgucken im hinterhalt mal kurz was notieren ich brauche auf meinem
klo ein ipad duschen auch aber ich auch beim auf dem klo sitzen deswegen brauche ich immer
ein ipad auf dem klo ich meine ich habe einen 3000 euro klo da kann ich da das ganze auch
noch aufwerten oder mit einem 350 euro ipad also wenn wenn schon denn schon das kann man
sich dann auch noch gönnen ein dediziertes klo tablet naja wasserfest ist es nicht hat
auch keine hülle und nix drum liegt aber im prinzip nur im bad also was soll was soll
passieren ja das ist wieder so chibay warum kriegen warum kriegen wir ein julian bam
video empfohlen
station band world record ok zeig mal schnell 118
der schickt den der schickt den jetzt irgendein porno ich dachte wunderbar
ich dachte wunderbar was der typ jetzt gemacht hat
und jetzt warten warten bis der band kommt oder was
ach nee jetzt ist gebannt temporär temporärer band geil und die kenner unter euch ich weiß
wir haben die teilweise die richtigen high fat weeps wer erkennt welches bild er ihm
geschickt hat ich habe keine ahnung wenn das ebaro jetzt da wäre ja wenn das ebaro
da wäre dem würde ich zutrauen das zu wissen ok damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
ich dachte der hätte irgendeinen exploit würde der aus nutzen wir dann gebannt aber
die brauchen ja teilweise ewig um irgendwelche cheater oder sonstige sachen zu bannen ja
dem offiziellen playstation account porn schicken ist wahrscheinlich die schnellste variante
gebannt zu werden kann ich mir vorstellen das war echt eine geile idee
ok leute betke ja die lesen die nachricht vielleicht ist das aber auch irgendeine super
advanced bild recognition software die ihn gebannt hat bestimmt nicht der einzige der
auf die idee gekommen ist warum mit 22 weil ich müde bin und ich absolut nichts geplant
habe für heute ich meine ich könnte jetzt noch eine halbe stunde hier sitzen in den
chat darin und wir könnten auch was labern aber ich bin müde und ich wir haben wir sind
die thema ausgegangen ich habe keine ahnung mehr hast du morgen frei nein leider nicht
muss morgen arbeiten ich habe aber das sogar absichtlich gemacht weil bei mir im team sind
so viele leute im urlaub da habe ich gesagt komm ich bleib da morgen passiert eh nix
guckt mal kurz rein vielleicht sollte ich das besser nicht man ich gucke mal kurz rein
in meinen kalender ob ich da irgendwas ich weiß ich habe irgendein gespräch mit meinem
chef morgen aber ansonsten leiter gar nichts moment wartet mal 27 hier gespräch max habe
ich um 10 mit meinem chef ok aber ansonsten habe ich den ganzen tag ein ein daily habe
ich 30 minuten sonst noch also im prinzip nur zwei meetings das ist ja erträglich ja
da passiert morgen morgen passiert nix kann morgen vielleicht ein paar sachen machen
ich sonst nicht machen kann weil mich die leute nerven den ganzen tag vielleicht aktualisiere
ich mal wieder alle meine tickets wird mal zeit ich habe da dinger die liegen teilweise
seit 2016 oder so rum kein witz ich habe die gehts von ich habe eins eins ich habe ein
ticket von 2016 sechs jahre altes ticket und das liegt aber auch gar nicht an mir dass
dann sich nichts tut da ging es darum dass irgendein server abgebaut abgelöst werden
soll und die anwendung die da drauf läuft ist nicht mehr so ported der hersteller macht
nichts mehr die leute die mitentwickelt haben gibt es nicht mehr und der server steht einfach
nur da mit einem docker container und tut so als wäre es in red hat vier kein witz red
hat vier und es ist in red hat fünf das so tut als wäre es in red hat vier findet ganz
schlimm und das ding ist halt einfach da und keiner macht mehr was und ich habe ein ticket
mal wo drin steht quasi abbauen aber ich kann den nicht abbauen weil die anwendung wird
noch gebraucht und keiner so ported sie und keiner macht da meinen handschlag dran also
im prinzip was soll ich machen ja außer die kiste stehen lassen
das ist eigentlich gar keine so blöde idee auf der anderen seite sorgt das meistens dann
auch für unnötig verwirrung weil dann manchmal sachen auftauchen wieder die die leute schon
vergessen haben eins versus eins loll genau heute macht man eins versus eins loll man früher
hat man gemacht eins versus eins duell rast quickscope only die hatten jungs sogar nur
noscope ja war es wahrscheinlich wert oder nein war wahrscheinlich nicht so wild also
die frage bezüglich linux geräteverwaltung beantwortet nee die habe ich gar nicht gesehen
die beantworte ich jetzt noch bevor ich oft gehe logi ach hier das habe ich nicht gesehen
wie hand habt ihr linux end user geräte auf der arbeit bezüglich verwaltung gar nicht
die haben alle windows geräte außer ein paar leute in meinem team die haben linux und man
möchte das eigentlich nicht offiziell aber inoffiziell haben wir keine so wirkliche alternative
und man hat sich wahrscheinlich überlegt die leute die bei uns linux geräte haben
könnten ohne problem jetzt auch einfach auf unser produktives storage und shutdown machen
vielleicht müssen wir die nicht so sehr kontrollieren also offiziell ist es nicht so gerne gesehen
inoffiziell haben wir keine andere möglichkeit und wir verwalten da gar nichts es sind aber
auch nur nur eine handvoll linux ich habe eins davon wir haben keine ahnung das ist
mal 67 linux endgeräte sein die wir haben die schaffen es ja nicht mehr rider zu kaufen
ich habe sogar ich habe sogar ein support ticket schon mal aufgemacht bei uns dass sie mir
eine rider lizenz kaufen sollen dann würde ich auch unter unter windows benutzen aber
kriegen sie nicht gebacken nachdem ich mal auch die ein oder andere sache weiterentwickeln
muss die ich so gebaut habe die letzten jahre über sehe ich das nicht ein mich da irgendwie
mit wishlist studio code unter windows rum zu quälen oder sowas und meine eigene lizenz
werde ich garantiert nicht verwenden auf eine arbeitswindows kiste soll ich jetzt pennen
wir sehen uns eventuell morgen schon und dann mit bisschen gebasteln wir sehen uns bis
dann machts gut ja schön dass du deinen weich her gefunden hast du bist nicht der erste der
mich so hier gefunden hat wahrscheinlich hast du den avatar gesehen hast du ja das habe ich
schon mal irgendwo gesehen ja schön dass du her gefunden hast aber ich gehe jetzt auf wir
sehen uns im nächsten stream bis denn machts gut zu